[Music]
man this kid is an asshole he rides
balloons to the moon to fish for what I
guess is cloud trout by the way you know
the dark part of the moon is supposed to
be silent and not a nesting crook for
delinquent kids right also as if you
needed any more proof that dreamworks
desperately wants to be pixar they rip
off the classic scene from up for the
opening logo wait up came out two years
after this
well dreamworks still totally wants to
be picked up Jesus movie are you trying
to go on Harry Potter on us I know
Prisoner of Azkaban was that series
third entry but this is a totally
different franchise full of magical
creatures and sentient animals and
wizards and operating and a protagonist
with two trusted allies and wait are you
even here doesn't look like anyone at
your table is excited to be here so it's
not like you got dragged in against your
will - so Pinocchio secretly loves
dinner theater and for that reason we
get this cheap wooden joke at least this
movie's telling me early on what passes
for humor do you my gingerbread man
would go on to transform into a
different magical creature Twitter troll
how is this vanity mirror even lit up
you might say candles but then I'd call
you a filthy liar because this is a
steady light bulb type of light oh yeah
I remember that storyline about the
fairy godmother in the last movie no me
either
I had to Wikipedia that point is at
least the second movie had the courtesy
to not depend totally on having the
knowledge of what happened in the first
one I get that this is a bed fit for a
king but before he turned back into a
frog a regular-sized King slept here
right with his regular-sized wife but it
can easily fit two grown-ass ogres oh I
know
isn't it wonderful I'm glad that the
Shrek franchise basically became The
Addams Family overtime to us is
wonderful to them
nice try a movie but no matter how cute
you try and make these dragon donkey
babies I'm always going to remember that
they're a crossbred unholy abomination
against God and man movie somehow misses
the chance to do something completely
on-brand and truthful by not calling
this Shrek the turd I'm not gonna play
this song for a number of reasons but
just trust me it's royal pain by the
eels which is a great song by an awesome
band so I continue to wonder how the
Shrek franchise can be so good at music
while being so terrible at movie
remember that time that Shrek either
killed or maimed a dude in front of a
large crowd with no repercussions
wait a minute how the sales catch fire I
suppose that's the joke but damn it I'm
gonna be thinking about those sales for
the rest of the movie damn movie you've
already ripped off Holy Grail with the
coconuts and Dumb and Dumber with the
toenail grinder in the first five
minutes you do know the difference
between homage and outright theft right
nope all right carry on
yeah but the king and queen from the
last movie never dressed like this if we
will go to all the lengths for one
stupid fucking sidekick oh hey get your
fat bastard out of my Shrek who do you
think we're kidding I am an ogre
isn't this the plot point of every Shrek
movie and how many times does he have to
remind us of this
what if theoretically yeah they were a
little ogre feet damn if this movie
takes a hard left into ocher porn I
gotta say it'd be much more on board
have you seen a baby lately they just
eaten poop and they cry when they poop
on their listing all the reasons babies
are terrible cliche aside I think this
was just the movies excuse to say poop a
million times in five seconds wait Shrek
has nipples clay has he always had
nipples and I've just never noticed it
and even so what are they for I haven't
had this many questions about
unnecessary nipples since Batman and
Robin don't forget to pay the god that
Lillian for explaining I am proud to
call you my son and I'm proud to call
you my frog King dad-in-law Oh Shrek
never change
you had Farquaad in the first movie and
you crazy comic dispensers have cracked
up all the sensors with this double
entendre
the Frog King movie directly inspires
the most irritating part of Deadpool -
it's a funeral so therefore it must rain
no matter what at this point in the
movie they're playing the wings version
of Live and Let Die and I have to ask
did anyone actually think this through
this is not a mournful song that pays
respect to a morose occasion like
hallelujah did in the first rap it's a
goddamn Bond theme Cinderella is in Far
Far Away right now eating bonbons wait
but Prince Charming just named off all
the actual plots that the villains in
the poem were involved with if
Cinderella is in this universe she
should be married to charming right if
you're gonna subvert fantasy movie at
least get your straight who wants their
happily ever
yeah charming ordered fuzzy navels for
everyone when he got to the bar but
Mabel hasn't made and the rest of the
place has been busy threatening him for
the last two minutes so where the hell
did these drinks come from also it's not
really a fuzzy navel I thought it's just
peach and orange juice but it's got like
pineapple and lime and I mean it could
be a fuzzy navel just like the drink
Jason Bateman orders in game night could
be a Harvey Wallbanger but I'm sending
it until I receive confirmation I don't
know you but I like to Wieck and none of
the other cats speak these cartoons are
really gonna have to get to the bottom
of this animal language puzzle also a
man this franchise assumes people have a
lot of interest in anthropomorphize
sexual activity
oh so also why can't Fionna go on this
voyage - Arthur is her family right and
she's been a badass up until now I
remember that matrix bolt against Robin
Hood in the first movie sure she's
pregnant
but Shrek doesn't know that I knew my
friend I royally what screwed is that
any worse than the Frog king thing this
movie got away with earlier movie that
barely scratches featurelength has time
for an extended dream sequence better
out than in I always say yes you do in
every incorrect movie when a man has a
certain feelings for a woman I know how
it happened yeah and here all this time
my shrek fanfic had him pulling out and
finishing on Fiona's - how does it
happen dude if you're gonna make this
joke make it with the character that
hasn't already fathered at least five
offspring when have you ever heard the
phrase as sweet as an ogre or as
nurturing as an ogre we can get it odors
are terrible you're worried about that
Jesus give it a rest had a trick even
know where to go Harold only got out
Arthur's name before he croaked and it
didn't even seem like lily and knew he
existed bro don't burn all my
frankincense in man yes at least one of
the screenwriters fought tooth and bond
keep this fucking stoner joke in the
script congratulations guy who wrote
Caddyshack - and wild wild west by how
did you receive the wedgies when you are
clearly not aware of the Underpants
let's just say some things are better
left unsaid and leave it at that the
only reason you were leaving this unset
is because it is a total lie the fact
that donkey is even leaving something
unsaid is proof enough for me so then I
was all like I rather get the Black
Plague and lock myself in an Iron Maiden
than go out with you
lines like this illustrate why movies
like Shrek should stay at one or two
chapters because every single time the
dialogue peppers medieval references
into modern lingo begins to pile up and
become stale
man this will be so derivative of other
movies that I totally believe that horse
just got hit by a golf ball remind me
why we're in high school for this
sequence I mean I guess it's
tangentially related to the Arthurian
fable but in high school what sense does
it make to any of this goddamn story
thank you to Professor Prynne bottom and
is invigorating lecture on how to just
say no I mean do you see what I mean
they got a million of them folks already
a king more like the mayor of Loserville
jeez even when the movie appears to try
to be self-aware it's so stupid you
think it might actually be serious
wait babies poop everyone poops Beauty
I'm adding a hundred sins for the poop
jokes in the anachronistic way people
talk in this movie it's goddamn
nauseating also this is a quick ass baby
shower right Shrek can have been gone
long we've only seen one night pass
Dover babies fully just eat in less than
a week I don't care what fantasy land
you're living in there is no way they
could expect Fiona to fit into that no
way dragon saw these assholes
approaching especially since we've seen
how she is it guarding castles in the
previous movies I see someone got the
Golden Snitch what the hell are the
trees from anyway if they're ents from
Lord of the Rings then they wouldn't be
villains if they're from blizzard of Oz
then they're really also not feelings
and they should be sporting apples in
what someone please tell me the logic of
this joke how does chasing people out of
a booter II suddenly turn it into
hooters I think the joke is that you can
easily change booter e into hooters and
I'm sorry I just don't get it to the
console why didn't they go there in the
first place then they now have to climb
up to the castle on foot just because
they wanted to do some light looting
stupids this line is appropriate because
this movie is definitely funnier than
the 1996 Tom Arnold vehicle the stupids
and that's about it
last time movie thinks it's got a cool
reflective shot but if hook is truly
threatening gingerbread man directly to
his face this is an impossible angle
screw me now everyone in this universe
goes to high school
couldn't exactly not say this or is
let's combine all the stuff that's
terrible about this movie with the
shrill character voices and guys so I
might have to stop sending this movie
it's that freaking awful the sink
counter says I have to finish this and I
always do what the master sets I just
figured everyone forgot about me
well it did get a little funky after you
left didn't sink but just to find was
the man I'm going back to what how is
this even a struggle
Shrek's been shown to have incredible
strength and newbies gone to great
lengths to show us what a pipsqueak
already is even if he's in panic mode
far far away from you you get back here
young man and I mean it guy and we'll
soon be a father learns fathering with
the surrogate son during an adventure
cliche I was merely a victim of a level
3 fatigue and at the request of my
therapist this is Eric idols voice right
because it sounds so much like John
Oliver then I'll never be able to listen
to John Oliver again without thinking he
stole Erik idols mojo to further his
career this is lame wow you're late
somehow the argument between Justin
Timberlake and the director made it into
the actual movie I get it my dad left
so what Luther issues whenever the movie
finds itself in a run somebody sings or
plays a modern song that was popular in
its day but relatively obscure now for
all the laps and inevitably all the
other characters hate the song and scorn
the person for singing and or playing it
Scooby is so tired that it's practically
is equal maybe it just bothers you that
I was voted fairest in the land man in a
sea of bad scenes made by talented
people in this movie the Princess seams
are absolutely the baddest we're gonna
get inside and find out what charmings
up - how does Fiona know that it was
Prince Charming that attacked the castle
he was way too far away for her to see
him before they escaped and even if she
had seen him there were like dozens of
other well-known villains that could
have been the ringleader but how long
have they been wandering the catacombs
like minutes right maybe a couple hours
but in that time Charming's taken over
the entire city and carved out an image
of his head into the hedges if rapunzel
was on charming side this whole time why
did she even bother going into the
secret passage with the rest of the
princesses flipping the bird also a
movie franchise can't resist the chance
to kill yet another bird as if it's got
a vendetta or some if the trees are this
angry and been here this whole night
then why didn't they attack them in
their sleep Oh
hooks piano blow up the whole plans
ruined run for it even though we have
nowhere to go I know you
do it I said forget it character says
he's not going to do something before
immediately doing that thing cliche
I've been abracadabra into a fancy face
and second-rate sidekick there's an
actual plot to this movie or was this
entire thing greenlit as is after the
first brainstorming meeting yeah you
should feel all exposed nasty what is he
talking about
donkey doesn't wear pants this is the
second time donkeys mentioned something
about pants look there's some weird
character trait where he's delusional
about pants he suddenly wears how did
far far away
shut down so quickly again it's only
been a few days since Trek even left so
even though charming took over the whole
city wouldn't end up like Hill Valley
and back to the future too that quickly
if you need to put five bucks into this
machine to see Pinocchio then who put
five bucks in the first time look at
this scene you can see the machine on
the left with Pinocchio inside of it did
the witch that's walking away from it
put five dollars into the Machine and
leave there's this machine along he's a
star people
hello I'm so sorry about this mr. Shrek
this is some how it works
who told you to stop dancing Wow Carmen
got a lot of authoritarian capital out
of one rousing speech at the bar and a
round of fuzzy navels let me guess
awesome how does everyone now know who
arthur is when the King only just
mentioned to him on his deathbed he's an
ogre what did you expect whoa hold on
now wait just a fucking second are you
telling me Shrek isn't a girl when did
this happen
why didn't anyone say anything so
they're just gonna let him go the second
rightful heir to the throne charming is
still planning on killing Tripp right
seriously this is the second sad music
montage for the movie and by my
unofficial count the 47th of the
franchise also the song that's playing
is Damien Rice's nine crimes which is
about infidelity in Jesus movie whose
because a song is slow and dour doesn't
mean it's perfect for a sad moment damn
this is a big castle to only have one
cell to put all the dissidents in
together
I suppose the journal about Sleeping
Beauty is that she's a narcoleptic and I
understand that the deal with these
Shrek movies is to be irreverent and
interpret fairy tales in a skewed and
humorous manner but knowing that
Sleeping Beauty only fell into her deep
deep sleep because of a curse and not
because of some sort of sleeping
disorder makes me wonder how long anyone
thought about giving her more of a
character than the tired narcolepsy
nonsense
if she could do this why didn't you do
it earlier okay because I mean also see
there's a whole other cell right there
why don't you just fight out dialogue
was personally approved by Roger Goodell
just now to have it this is funny and
all but it's guaranteed that when we see
all these women again no one will be
sporting a pair of pokies consistent
with the choice who would have thought a
monster like me deserves something as
special as you man you think there'd be
a better way into the castle than this
overly complicated plant like couldn't
Lillian have just head-butted an
interior wall Wow hey how's it gone see
it's funny because she's ugly even
though she's apparently got attractive
legs and guys are horny laughing yet he
was using me that's all there is to it
Shrek only said those things to protect
you this is one of the only times when
saying something or not saying something
in order to protect you is actually used
correctly but my sins filter still wants
to sin it simply because they said those
magic words that I hate so after Prince
Charming became king he still wanted to
put on this stupid play about beating
Shrek like he did at the beginning of
the movie when he was clearly at his
lowest point oh just be king not like he
even knew Shrek was in line to be the
heir look is this movie about really
wish they had given this warning at the
beginning of the movie that's actually a
very nice leotard thank you did they
come in men's sizes this has got to be
like the fifth man is a woman joke in
the movie but I'm too pissed at it to go
check just like every Shrek movie the
dragon comes into X Mach and other
proceedings feel like they could just
take this dragon anywhere and no one
would ever put them during their stupid
schemes but Who am I to judge I'm not
even mad about the stupid poop joke I'm
just sad that everyone fucking does this
joke and it's neither funny nor clever
no matter what character is doing it
there was no screwing things this time
oh go kids but make sure to do it all
slow and stuff so I can actually finish
jerking off for once the thing that
matters most is what you think of
yourself
is anyone buying this as a speech really
gonna turn the tide here god dammit holy
this could not be more telegraph but no
one moved a muscle except the one
motherfucker who's chained to the floor
yeah the guy we've never met no I heard
about is going to be keying whoo I have
something much more important
mind what so shrek school with the
Fatherhood now he just faced down an
asshole that wanted to kill him and let
Artie take over as king and nothing
about that would prepare him for having
a kid plus I had a perfect Cameron Diaz
audio outtake from Vanilla Sky queued up
for whatever Fiona inevitably yelled at
Trek for being a dick dammit this movie
for that alone please I guess everyone
thought this guy was going to be such a
hit that the filmmakers gave him another
scene at the end that's too bad
I was kind of hoping they forgot about I
hate so much about the things that you
choose to be working if you think this
whole mad scene ain't dope I feel you
don't mess with me I'm one crazy mofo I
had to pop a cop because he wasn't
giving my props in Oaktown so so just go
I'm gone get it
I am go I'm gone coconut and you're
banging him together
once upon a time someone decided that we
were the losers
and get in my belly Fox force five Fox
and then we're a bunch of foxy chicks
force and then were forced to be
reckoned with
then fives and is one two people in five
it